it took a long time
and a lot of work to get this far 155
delegates representing all sectors of
chilean society
this is the historic moment when
executive secretary of the electoral
commission
carmen gloria vagidares swore them in
but the inauguration was delayed by
protests inside the convention hall by
those not happy with the procedure
and clashes outside between police and
demonstrators
this is an assembly designed to heal the
divisions in chilean society
the newly elected president is elisa
long gone from the mapuche indigenous
people
half the convention members are women 17
seats are filled by representatives of
indigenous communities
of course this is an historic day which
we've won with a tough fight and a lot
of pain
the chilean people the indigenous people
are now able to abolish pinochet's
evil constitution this is a time of hope
[Music]
other delegates represent the lgbtq
community
and those with disabilities 65 are
independents who belong to none of
chile's established political parties
never before in chile have we elected
people in this way
this is an unforgettable moment unique
for those of us representing social
movements
in the fight for the dignity lost for
more than 30 years
[Music]
outside others are still demanding
justice for human rights abuses
committed during military rule
we really hope this will bring about
change in chile that we'll see a change
today
the people want change not more of the
same
the new assembly will have up to a year
to draft a new constitution that will
replace the one imposed in 1980
under the pinochet military government
it will then have to be approved by the
chilean people in a mandatory vote
the new assembly came about after mass
protests in 2019
that highlighted the huge inequalities
in chilean society
that tens of thousands felt they were
being left out of the political process
they hope they can now begin to address
those divisions
but few are expecting it to be easy
danish
al jazeera